[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le 78 weekend
nous allons nous intéresser à ce qui
fait l'actualité culturelle et des
loisirs à Saint-Quentin en ivelin et
puis dans le courant de l'émission nous
parlerons d'un concert donné le 1er
décembre par l'Ensemble Vocal de 50 ans
en Yveline à mes côté Val Ros bonjour
pour m'accompagner pour cette émission
un concert dans un lieu prestigieux on
va en parler la commanderie des
Templiers à encour on se dit que le son
doit être beau à la commande des
Templiers vous direz ça dans quelques
instants mais d'abord donc direction le
cinéma UGC de5 qu1 en yeline pour la
marche ce film qui retrace la marche
contre le racisme et parmi les acteurs
du film Jamel de boous trapiste
d'origine qui est donc revenue sur cette
terre un un sujet signé aurellia debici
dimanche l'UGC de SaintQuentin accueillé
Jamel de Bou trapiste d'origine et
l'équipe du film La Marche à l'occasion
d'une projection en avant-première un
long métrage librement inspiré de la
marche pour l'égalité et contre le
racisme mouvement qui 30 ans plus tôt
dénoncer les conditions des immigrés en
France une marche pacifiste partie de
Marseille le 15 octobre 1983 pour
rejoindre Paris avec un cortège de
100000 personnes en décembre bien que la
sore du film soulève au regard de
l'actualité la question du sens de la
marche aujourd'hui pour l'équipe de
tournage il s'agit surtout de retracer
des faits
historiques aujourd'hui c'est une
histoire assez extraordinaire de voir
des jeunes inspirés par Gandy qui
décident d'organiser une marche non
violente pour l'égalité contre le
racisme ça raisonne mais c'est avant
tout un sujet cinématographique en or
qui plus a une histoire vraie donc je
pense que malheureusement ou
heureusement pour certains les agendas
concordent et on se dit que ce film a
besoin d'être vu maintenant et on sent
on se voilà on est flatté pour ça mais
mais mais c'est avant tout une grande
histoire
cinématographique un hommage au
marcheurs et l'ambiance qui y régnait
que les comédiens sont fiers de
présenter peu de gens connaissent la
marche il y a eu un sondage il y a pas
longtemps qui disait que 80 entre 80 et
90 % des jeunes n'étaient pas au courant
de cette marche donc si grâce à ce film
on peut on peut rendre hommage déjà aux
vrais marcheurs et puis leur fournir
surtout un un beau film nous on est très
très fier d'abord comme comédien
évidemment jouer ce genre de partition
moi joue un toxico roublard ça m'était
jamais arrivé j'en connaissais
plein et et défendre ce genre d'idée de
propos qui rassemble la France racontez
cette histoire d'amour pour la France à
travers cette jeunesse c'était pour
moi c'est vraiment une chance c'était un
super film ou très très bien très
émouvant aussi par rapport à ce que ces
marcheurs à l'époque ont vécu hein parce
qu'ils ont vécu quand même des des
mauvaises choses he par par les Français
faut le dire faut pas que ça se
reproduise sortie nationale du film le
27 novembre la justice n'est pas un
acquis elle est le fruit de la
révolte un tout autre sujet alors vous
aimez cuisiner bien ça tombe bien car
vous êtes diton de plus en plus nombreux
à vous mettre au fourneau les émissions
de télé consacré la cuisine remporte de
Fran succès et le département des Vivin
a fait le choix de surfit sur la vague
en proposant jusqu'au 1er décembre une
opération qui s'appelle good Evelin et
cela a démarré avec un battle de cuisine
évidemment on y
était beaucoup de concentration pour
David il est breton et vient participer
au premier battle de cuisine organisé
dans le cadre de l'opération good
Eveline ce négociateur immobilier est un
passionné de cuisine présélectionné sur
internet il a envie de bien faire c'est
une passion après un trempelin pourquoi
pas vous la vie est faite d'opportunités
donc aujourd'hui CEN est une face à lui
Francis lui est de Lyon il a déjà
participé au dîner presque parfait dans
la vie Francis travaille dans une agence
de publicité quatre cuisiniers amateurs
qui doivent préparer des recettes en 15
minutes seulement à partir de produits
locaux un fromage frais de saintréi les
chevreuses des champignons de Paris de
montaesson et du miel des ivelines c'est
produits quand même
particulier à travailler à sublimer et
du coup on a il faut vraiment faire
Preve d'imagination et d'essayer de
trouver à la fois d'originalité
peut-être dans les mélanges et les SA et
trouver peut-être deux trois astuces qui
peuvent être techniques qui peuvent
permettre de se démarquer mais c'est
vrai que ça va très très vite quoi à
leur côté pour les conseillers de vrais
chef David est épaulé par Laurent
trochin installé au Tremblet sur moldre
et le restaurateur le reconnaît la
cuisine est une valeur sûre on aime le
produit on aime le bon produit et on
aime manger et et de plus en plus on a
vu revenir en même temps les ménagers
refaire à manger aujourd'hui des
cuisiniers amateurs ben font aussi bien
ou mieux je veux dire que certains
restaurants c'est pour ça que certains
désertent les restaurants parce qu'ils
trouvent qu'ils font assez à manger chez
eux parmi les conseils que Laurent a
disyé ce jour-là surtout s'amuser et
prendre du plaisir les joutes culinaires
ont été remporté cocorico par une
yvelinoise l'orcane de vilisy
l'opération goodeline se poursuit
jusqu'au 1er décembre avec des ateliers
de cuisine des menus spéciaux toujours à
partir de produits
locaux ah oui on aurait bien aimé goûter
Val je vous VO salumé on aurait bien
aimé vous êtes à la matrice de cuisine
grande c'est un grand moment de détente
pour moi un grand moment de détente
d'accord en plus de de chanter la moment
de détente alors êtes-vous justement
amateur de cuisine et notamment à la
télévision c'est la question que nous
sommes allés vous poser dans les rues de
CTIN on écoute vos réponses avec
Faustine Bollart là sur les les gâteaux
par c'est axé sur la pâtisserie parce
que ça apprend plein de choses et puis
ça permet de voir qu'il y a des gens
novic qui savent faire de la pâtisserie
de façon exceptionnelle al il m'est
arrivé de regarder mais pas pas de façon
assidu je dirais et je préfère aller au
restaurant que de que de m'aventurer
dans la cuisine toutes celles qui
parlent de recettes et qui sont
explicatives surtout parce que j'adore
cuisiner
lesquels j'ai pas de titre en tête mais
j'aime bien les carnets de Julie par
exemple je crois que c'est comme ça que
ça s'appelle ça ça ne m'intéresse pas
c'est la compétition qui m'intéresse pas
je préfère voir les recettes tout
simplement mais bon tout ce qui est sur
Oui TF1 ou M6 tout ces chosesl non ça
m'intéresse pas du tout Top Chef comme
ça ouais voilà ouis c'est intéressant
oui j'aime bien de temps en temps ça
change qu'est-ce que vous aimez dans ces
émissions le dynamisme des gens pour
réaliser quelque chose de de correct non
je ne regarde pas par que pourquoi ça
vous intéresse pas ça m'intéresse pas
non non pourtant je suis j'aime bien la
cuisine j'aime bien manger mais non ça
ne m'intéresse pas al on va passer
maintenant
l'entretienos bonjour direct artistique
de l'Ensemble Vocal de 50 ans m' dit moi
j'aime bien cuisiner mais je regarde pas
non plus les émissions de télé comme le
monsieur le dernier exactement mais ça
dépend en fait de du mode de
fonctionnement de chacun mais c'est vrai
que j'adore être devant les fourneaux
ouais parce que vous avez dit ça détend
oui mais c'est stressant le de
chanter non ce n'est pas stressant de
chantter mais c'est très détendant de
manger d'accord alors vous êtes en
plateau avec nous aujourd'hui parce que
l'ensemble vocal de 50 ans niine va
investir de nouveau pour un deuxième
concert la commanderie des Templiers à
hencour vous étiez venus en plateau
d'ailleurs pour nous parler de ce
premier concert qui avait lieu à
l'occasion des journées du patrimoine et
puis là le prochain aura lieu le 1er
décembre j'ai envie de dire puisquon est
dans la la cuisine vous y prenez
vraiment goût à la commande des templier
et c'est facile d'y prendre goût parce
qu'on se dit que l'endroit doit être
magique c'est c'est magique et on invite
vraiment les personnes qui avaient pas
pu se déplacer pour les journées du
patrimoine à venir pour cette visite à
de voix puisque en fait il y a la visite
de la Commanderie avec une personne du
musée de la ville de la communauté
d'agloot et qui se termine pour
déboucher sur la chapelle et découvrir
l'acoustique exceptionnel de ce lieu
puisque sur l'ensemble de la ville
nouvelle il n'y a pas d'autres lieux qui
sonne comme la Commanderie alors comment
ça se fait qu' pas d'aut autres lieux
qui sonent parce qu'il y a des églises
quand même et ben il y a des églises
mais qui avaient été qui avaient été
structuré pour simplement une acoustique
d'église là cette chapelle elle a une
capacité étonnante c'est qu'elle
raisonne comme une cathédrale alors
Valéri Jos moi je vous dis je vois pas
trop la différence entre une église
entre le son dans une église et le son
dans une cathédrale je me dis peut-être
que le son dans une cathédrale est plus
ouvert du coup il est plus fort RA ça
raésonne beaucoup plus un tout petit son
de vraiment de très très basse intensité
on on a l'impression que ça raisonne
comme dans une cathédrale donc les
fausses notes s'entendent très bien
aussi et on essaie de ne pas en faire de
trop ça c'est le message parce queig trs
percioniste ça c'est le message qui est
envoyé à ses choristes pour dire en gros
il faut être parfait mais ça veut dire
que quand vous faites des répétitions
avec vos choristes effectivement il y a
un travail qui est qui est différent que
dans une sur le son exactement sur le
son c'est-à-dire la qualité sonore
c'est-à-dire l'ensemble des pupitres
évidemment comme d'habitude on imagine
que les pupites sont bien homogènes que
toutes les voix sont bien jolies mais là
en plus dans cette perspective c'est
qu'on se promène autour du public donc
les choristes sont vraiment très proches
du public et bien évidemment s'il faut
se not il a une fois qu'elle est sortie
on ne peut plus faire quoi que ce soit
non ça c'est clair ça veut dire que vous
leur demandez V coris de de baisser le
la voix alors de ne pas chanter trop
fort exactement de bien chanter trop
fort parce que pardon ce serait
inaudible ou ce serait désagréable à
l'oreille ça serait très désagréable à
l'oreille tout de suite ça raisonne
énormément on est sur une capacité de
décibel qui peut être désagréable on a
fait des essais sans public et où on a
en effet même nous on était pas à l'aise
tellement on était dans un univers Sonor
trop sonore et ça c'est facile pour des
choristes d'arriver à baisser la voix de
pas se laisser emporter par le le champ
comme ça vocal c'est pas si simple et
c'est vrai qu'il faut s'entraîner et
c'est très agréable de s'entraîner parce
que c'est quelque chose de différent par
rapport au aux différents moments où on
peut travailler au théâtre de cquentin
ou ailleurs là on est dans un endroit où
on doit respecter cet acoustique je vis
revenir sur ce que vous avez dit ça vous
dites que les chistes sont à travers le
le public oui une déambulation il y a
une déambulation on commence comme un
concert entre guillemets c'estàdire o où
le public est assis et le cœur dans le
cœur de la chapelle et puis on entoure
le public pour leur permettre de se
rendre compte que justement les les
l'univers acoustique est très différent
suivant où se place les cororiste et on
finit on n pas le même à chaque
endroit et vous me disiez en préparant
cet entretien qu'il y avait aussi des
expérimentations sonores et c'est ça ces
expérimentations sonores voilà
exactement et une exp tion en fait aussi
qui est très intéressante sur ce concert
là c'est qu'on va mettre en parallèle la
musique du Moyen-Âge comment on chantait
au Moyen-Âge puisque le thème et si
j'étais moine à la villeedieu donc on va
chanter des de la musique sacrée mais on
va mettre en parallèle la musique de
Poulin puisquon rend hommage cette année
au 50 ans de la mort de Poulin et Poulin
s'est beaucoup inspiré de la musique du
Moyen-Âge or le faire à l'intérieur
d'une chapelle c'est génial donc on
alternera des morceaux contemporains
presque et des morceaux du moyen ou
parce que je voulais en venir au au
programme alors j'ai commencé
l'entretien en parlant parce que j'ai
suis quand même assez fasciné par ce son
et par ce lieu de la Commanderie est
templier qui est porteur de tellement
d'histoirees et surtout qui a été qui a
été fermé pendant très longtemps donc
voilà il revenir je présume que c'est
aussi beaucoup beaucoup d'émotions alors
effectivement la dernière fois vous
étiez venu c'était pour parler d'un
concert qui s'appelait si j'étais
pèlerin voilà et alors là le concert
s'appelait si j'étais moine c'est
presque pareil non pas du tout parce que
quand on était pèlerin on venait se
réfugier à la Commanderie des Templiers
quand on était moine au contraire on
était là pour pria c'est complètement
une autre attitude c'est quelque chose
qui permettait la vie des Templiers hein
c'était le le templier était là aussi
pour prier euh le 3ème épisode puisque
3è épisode il y aura ça sera si j'étais
musicien et ça c'était aussi la place
des trouves et des troubadour qui se
promenaient comme les pèlerins et qui
amenaient une autre sorte de musique
donc là cette fois-ci moine à la ville
Dieu il n'y aura que de la musique
sacrée et souvent beaucoup de choses par
rapport à Noël puisqu'on se rapproche
des fêtes de Noël est-ce que vous pouvez
nous donner un ou deux titres ou urors
par Poulin bien évidemment alors tous
les tous les auteurs en fait on peut pas
vous donner d'auteur puisque les moines
à cette époque là ne chantaient
pratiquement que des mélodies
grégoriennes ou des des très vieux
textes qu'on appelle dans les manuscrits
le manuscrit de Montpellier le manuscrit
de Bamberg mais dans tous les cas c'est
la musique du 13e siècle c'est de la
vieille vieille musique la vieille
musique il y a des choristes mais pas
seulement il y a aussi des
euh j'ai cherchais comment s'appelle la
personne qui fait de la flute à bec
s'appelle FL une personne qui flutiste
qui est flu voilà tout simplement trois
personnes qui viennent jouer des
instrumentistes pour nous accompagner
puisqueà cette époque- làà bien
évidemment bah la musique était soutenu
par des instruments comme la flute avec
par exemple
voilà on voit des images de de
l'ensemble vocal qui est sur les marches
de la ville Dieu alors cette fois-ci
nous n'accueillerons pas le public sur
les marches de la Villedieu parce qu'il
fait trop froid et que l'intérieur de la
Villedieu est chauffé et qu'on sera très
très bien à l'INT donc vous serz bien au
showud le 1er décembre à 15h donc pour
ce concert en plus il faut préciser que
l'entrée est libre l'entrée est
totalement libre doncê il y a même pas
une petite qute à la fin commeig non
d'accord il y a pas il a pas tout ça
donc et le troisème concert alors pour
ceux qui veulent prendre date ça sera le
6 avril et donc là ça sera plutôt de la
musique de trouadour alors exactement
trou et trouadour et et si les personnes
ont envie de nous nous rejoindre bien
évidemment que l'ensemble vocal continue
à recruter bah oui c'est la question que
j'allais vous poser et voil voà
exactement alors on a un atelier au
théâtre de Saint-Quentin et l'atelier
est toujours ouvert au théâtre de
Saint-Quentin et les personnes qui
souhaiteraient pouvoir
exceptionnellement pendant un an venir
avec nous chanter et bien ils n'ont qu'à
se rapprocher du théâtre de SaintQuentin
d'accord donc il faut avoir quand même
une belle voix puisque veros nous l'a
dit quand on chante à la command
tempamplier il y a pas intérêt de faire
de fausses notes c'est ça non non non
non on accepte les fausses notes au
début pendant les répétition il faut
répéter beaucoup en musique ouais après
voilà ça une fois une fois qu'on c'est
un travail de répétition mais c'est
aussi un travail de de talent quand même
et de passion en fait il faut
transmettre une espèce de passion une
espèce d'énergie qui est indispensable
pour le chant c'est vrai qu'on peut pas
chanter comme on chante entre guillemets
dans sa salle de bain d'accord mais
depuis le l'ensemble vocal de
Saint-Quentin a été cré en 95 il a
depuis largement évolué Oui au niveau du
son énormément je remercie tous les
chistes là pour une fois il va y avoir
un message non subliminal je remercie
l'ensemble des chistes qui ont partagé
notre histoire il y en a plein qui ne
font plus partie de l'Ensemble Vocal
hein bien souvent on reste 4 5 ans à
l'Ensemble Vocal des fois un peu plus
longtemps il y en a qui sont là depuis
les presque 20 ans puisque 95 ben vous
avez soulevé un sujet qui sera un scoop
l'année prochaine nous nous faiterons
nos 20 ans et nous allons y associer
l'ensemble de la en 2015 oui 2014 2015
et oui la prochaine année c'est c'est
notreimagine même pas ce que vous allez
nous réserver pour les 20 ans alors là
ça va être un programme de le scoop la
prochaine fois d'accord merci en tout
cas sur le plateau du 78 weekend donc
nous parler de ce concert qui aura lieu
le 1er décembre à 15h dans le lieu
magnifique de la Commanderie templier
àencour et en plus c'est gratuit alors
il faut en profiter pour découvrir cette
musique du du Moyen-Âge qui est une
musique sacrée qui est très belle
essayie de prendre une voile de
cathédrale merci beaucoup Valérie Jos
allez on va maintenant parler dansse
avec une troupe peut-être que vous
connaissez black blomber ou voilà
incontournable sur 50 ans en Yveline la
troupe 5tinoise a été créée par Jean
gemad elle elle va fêter ses 30 ans la
troupe black blomber mais avant cela en
guise d'apéritif si l'on peut dire des
spectacles sont proposés et notamment il
y aura un spectacle ce samedi à 20h30 à
la meurise de trappe c'est paradoxe
c'est le nom du spectacle avec des
danseurs en devenir John jemad est venu
nous en parler justement sur le plateau
du 78 lactu on l'écoute voilà des gens
qui sont venus non seulement de leur
plein gré mais par par désir par goût
pour pratiquer la danse qui ont tous un
emploi et qui sont donc des jeunes gens
et des jeunes filles originaires de
trappp et de anttin en liveline qui
travaille avec nous depuis maintenant
près de 3 ans sur ce processus de
création euh c'est tout pas du jour au
lendemain qu'ils se sont retrouvés sur
la scène vous avez vraiment accompagné
tout au long de de ces différents ent
non seulement ils sont pas retrouvés du
jour au lendemain sur la scène mais ils
avaient envie eux de faire un vrai
spectacle de qualité donc on s'est pris
le temps de le faire et surtout l'idée
c'était que ils ont apprécié que nous ne
souhaitions pas leur imposer une
thématique ou une démarche et il faut
prendre le temps quand on travaille
ensemble parce que on parle de
coélaboration de CO création mais pour
cela il faut évidemment que nos
partenaires ces jeunes gens et ces
jeunes filles aent le temps de
construire une réflexion de l'
et voilà donc nous sommes partis de leur
envie de de faire
spectacle une idée au départ qui était
un peu la vengeance des pauvres contre
les riches et c'était spontanément ce
qui voulait mettre en forme donner à
voir et nous sommes parvenus Christine
notamment qui les a accompagné avec
Mathieu Raguel tout au long de ce
parcours son je rappelle un chorégraphe
qui a fondé avec vous la compagnie
absolument et qui est surtout la
personne référente de ce projet c'est
celui que les danseurs et danseuses en
question voient régulièrement euh nous
sommes parvenus à un spectacle dont le
titre est paradoxe mais qui va traiter
du paradoxe de la richesse ce qui est
quand même une sorte de mise à distance
où disons la vengeance la colère le le
sentiment un peu spontané a été remis de
côté pour évoquer peut-être plus
largement la question de qu'est-ce que
être riche ce sera à découvrir samedi à
partir de 20h30 à la merurise il reste
encore des places si vous souhaitez y
assister il y a aussi de représentant
pour les scolaires 21 2 novembre
peut-être faites-vous partie de des
parents dont les enfants vont revenir le
soir vous parler d'un spectacle ce sera
celui-ci paradoxe il faudra ensuite
aller le voir le samedi voici un petit
extrait un petit
[Musique]
teaser
une famille de jou en Josas à l'origine
d'une cabane totalement novatrice elle
est faite à partir de carton cclé
modulable elle peut donc se monter se
démonter en quelques minutes et
peut-être décoré selon ses propres goûts
alors l'approche évidemment de Noël
l'idée pourrait peut-être séduire bon
nombre de parents et d'enfants yolen
Torz avec ses cinq associés famille et
amis Corine était certaine que le
produit existait déjà pourtant leur idée
est totalement novatrice ces cabanes en
carton recyclé et modulable n'existe nul
part ailleurs pas même à l'étranger vous
pouvez vraiment créer la forme de la
cabane que vous souhaitez c'est deux
jeux en un vous pouvez d'une créer la
forme de la cabane donc ça peut être une
forme octogonale ça peut être un
labyrinthe ça peut être une maison avec
différentes petites pièces où les
enfants peuvent se cacher et ensuite
l'enfant peut décorer la cabane donc
vraiment le côté novateur c'est pour la
première fois construire la cabane qu'on
veut créer son univers créer son décor
créer son monde et vous verrez que les
enfants créent en fait à chaque fois à
chaque fois qu'il ressortent la cabane
vont créer une forme de cabane
différente ça sera jamais la même l'idée
est liée à son enfance son père était
publ ire et ramener souvent les cartons
qui ne servaient plus à la maison avec
ses deux frères Corine s'en servait
alors pour créer des cabanes ces cabanes
mabarac sont commercialisés depuis le
mois de septembre avant Corine a testé
son produit auprès des centres de
loisirs résultat un produit solide non
dangereux mais surtout très pédagogique
pour les enfants avec le système
d'encoche ils apprennent à maîtriser
leurs gestes mais pas seulement ça va
permettre également de développer la
créativité et l'imagination de l'enfant
puisqu'il va créer à chaque fois une
cabane différente et également
l'imagination et la créativité puisqu'il
va la décorer selon ses propres envies
dès l'âge de 3 ans la cabane peut se
monter et se démonter en 3 4 minutes
chrono démonstration avec deux des trois
enfants de
Corine l'idée semble faire des adeptes
sur leur première production Corine et
son équipe en ont déjà vendu la moitié
tout est stocké dans son garage donc ici
nous avons départ commandé 400 cabanes
il nous en reste reste plus que 200
puisque nous avons écoulé déjà la moitié
du stock et nous avons encore beaucoup
de de voyers tout ça ce sont des boîtes
qui sont en attente de livraison pour
des hôpitaux pour des centres de
vacances ou encore pour des écoles
l'activité lui prend beaucoup de place
et de temps mais elle reste pour le
moment un plus par rapport à son premier
métier de maîre de conférence en
marketing ce qui ne l'empêche pas
d'avoir déjà d'autres idées de
développement créer du mobilier en
carton pour meubler la cabane ou encore
créer le même produit en version plus
petite pour en faire des maisons de
poupée Corine et son équipe n'ont pas
fini d'innover à l'approche de Noël ma
Barac risque de faire quelques heureux
ils seront d'ailleurs présents au marché
Noël de juouill en Josas les 13 et 14
décembre
prochains allez notez-le sur vos agendas
du 6 au 18 décembre c'est la fête du
compte à 50 ans en Yveline le compte les
compteurs un monde assez merveilleux où
l'imaginaire a toute sa place est sur le
plateau du kiosque mercredi Laurence
Cantau et Johann Lavabre sont venus nous
parler de leur façon de définir le trava
de compteur qu'est-ce qu'on attend en
fait d'un compte'est qu'est-ce qui est
merveilleux dans comp ils sont pas tous
merveilleux he ils sont pas tous
merveilleux on attend d'être dans un
autre univers de s'identifier au héros
au pluriel et de pouvoir dépasser une
situation qui peut être pénible et
cetera à travers ces hos dont on
s'identifie on attend de nous transposer
juste par le son de la voix par le par
cette communique
dans un autre monde qui n'est plus le
qui n'est plus le sien donc voilà le
héros permet de grandir le héros permet
de dire B moi je suis capable de je peux
aussi y arriver et ça fait du bien
d'accord donc que ce soit finalement
pour les enfants ou ad on encore besoin
de rêver aussi voilà donc là j'en
profite pour parler d'un d'un spectacle
qui va avoir lieu le 7 décembre à 11h à
voisin bretonnais organisé par la
médiathèque saint-exuper qui seront des
comptes coquins autour de la fontaine et
réservés pour les adultes le compteur
est un passeur c'est un passeur
d'histoire donc ce n'est pas quelqu'un
qui joue mais c'est quelqu'un qui
raconte et donc la différence transmet
il transmet donc il n'est pas dans
l'incarnation il il ne revit pas les les
oripos d'un d'un personnage donc voilà
c'est c'est la différence essentielle
sinon il y a aussi cette notion
d'adresse directe au public il ne parle
pas à un autre personnage il parle au
public souvent avec une part de Li
liberté une part
d'improvisation le compteur c'est aussi
quelqu'un qui a un répertoire qui a
beaucoup d'histoire derrière lui qui est
capable comme ça la demande d'embrayer
sur une histoire ou sur une
autre et pour finir ce 78 weekend le
coup de cœur ciné de la semaine c'est à
retrouver tous les mercredis dans
kiosque l'émission culturelle présentée
Parel a de bici et cette semaine Grégory
Pagano du cinéma Philippe Noiret des
clés sous bois aujourd'hui j'ai envie de
vous parler d'un film d'animation un
film qui a été primé au festival d'Any
en 2013 un festival qui fait référence
en la matière il s'agit de maman est en
Amérique elle a rencontré Buffalo Bill
un très beau film très émouvant
également puisque il raconte la vie d'un
petit garçon de 6 ans qui cherche un peu
sa maman et qui pense qu'elle est en
voyage mais malheureusement on va se
rendre compte que c'est pas le cas et
que c'est une situation un peu plus
compliquée et c'est donc
cette ce problème du deuil qui va être
traité dans le film avec beaucoup
d'émotion qui sur les neiges du
Kilimanjaro avec des amis
non ce film a été adapté d'une bande
dessinée qui avait eu également un joli
succès et c'est la preuve aussi que les
films d'animation ne sont pas que pour
les enfants même si celui-ci c'est très
bien de le voir en famille et d'être là
avec les enfants pour pouvoir leur
expliquer un petit peu ce qui se passe
mais c'est aussi un film que les adultes
aont beaucoup de plaisir à voir non
seulement parce que le sujet est très
fort et très émouvant mais aussi parce
que c'est un film qui est plein de
nostalgie plein de poésie et plein
d'humour aussi
avec une histoire qui se passe pendant
les années 70 et donc qui nous
rappellera sûrement pour beaucoup
d'entre nous des souvenirs d'enfance
maman est en Amérique elle a rencontré
Buffalo Bill c'est 7 semaines à l'espace
Philippe noir je m'a fait manger des
crottes de
nez et avant de nous quitter deux
sorties coup de cœur pour ce weekend
tout d'abord le Salon du livre
d'histoire qui se tient à versaill
samedi et dimanche en 25 auteurs présent
rien que cela avec des noms prestigieux
comme Frédéric mitteran Franck Ferrand
Robert solet ou encore F2 Castro et bien
d'autres et puis pour pour les amateurs
de photos 19 photographes professionnels
et amateurs réunis à NAF le château
toujours samedi et dimanche 220 images
inédites à découvrir à la Maison du Jeu
de Paume ce 78 weekend est terminé merci
de votre attention je vous souhaite un
excellent weekend à très
[Musique]
bientôt